Telltale Games brought its trademark
interactive storytelling expertise to
Gotham City with 2016 s Batman the
telltale series this five-part episodic
adventure presented us with a grand new
Batman universe which meant surprising
new interpretations of classic
characters and plot twists that kept
even hardcore fans guessing refreshingly
it also gave players the chance to
experience life outside the cowl
depicting the tumultuous fortunes of
Bruce Wayne as he is forced to deal with
some shocking home truths and now The
Dark Knight Returns in the sequel Batman
the enemy within the first episode of
which titled the Enigma is available
right now but before you heed the call
of the bat-signal here's a recap of the
key events of the first season brought
to you by Telltale Games caution there
are major spoilers ahead but oh you're
trying to create a myth but be careful
you don't turn into a monster classic
Batman law has always portrayed Bruce
Wayne's parents as honorable
philanthropists gunned down in cold
blood in the very city they were trying
to save and while they share the same
fate in the telltale series the
motivation behind their grisly demise is
entirely different Intel tells Batman
universe Bruce is faced with the
revelations that Thomas Wayne colluded
with mob boss carmine Falcone and
corrupt mayor Hamilton Hill to control
Gotham he laundered money abused his
position as a doctor to condemn
political and financial rivals to the
local Asylum and even ordered the
assassination of the Arkham family when
they objected to his methods when his
wife Martha attempts to force Thomas to
sever all ties with his criminal
associates by threatening to reveal his
dark secrets its Mayor Hill that orders
their assassination
which is staged to look like a mugging
gone tragically awry smell it Falcone
while you still it's their ways this
knowledge not only throws Bruce's
motivations for becoming the Batman into
question but indelibly tarnishes the
legacy of the Wayne family the timing of
this devastating information is clearly
tactical arriving on the 20th
anniversary of Thomas and Martha's death
and amid the election for mayor where
Bruce is publicly backing his friend and
District Attorney Harvey Dent to use her
Hamilton Hill from his long-held role it
transpires that the leak came courtesy
of a mysterious terrorist organization
known as the children of Arkham
led by the mask tool ad hoc in their
efforts to expose Gotham's corrupt
underbelly and seize control of the city
they are employing an upgraded version
of the same psychogenic chemical used by
Bruce's father to send their targets
into an uncontrollable violent rage as
the world's greatest detective
investigates the reasons behind the
children of Arkham's actions his public
facing persona faces a battle against
hostile public opinion and the
shareholders of Wayne Enterprise things
are complicated further still by the
appearance of childhood friend Oswald
Cobblepot whose parents were victims of
Thomas Wayne's misdeeds and master thief
for hire Selina Kyle who just happens to
be in a relationship with Harvey Dent
the children of Arkham's campaign of
chaos continues drugging police officer
Renee Montoya in order to kill carmine
Falcone and with the aid of cobblepot's
criminal to Rico the penguin murdering
Hamilton Hill and depending on the
choices made by the player permanently
disfiguring Harvey Dent an attempt to
disperse an improved version of the drug
in a heavily populated area of Gotham
via a train is spectacularly
by Batman and camel ultimately though
even Bruce falls victim to the
children's schemes publicly assaulting
Kaaba bot in a psychogenic drug-induced
rage as a result of his outburst he is
condemned to Arkham Asylum by the now
unhinged mayor dent who believes that
Bruce is having an affair with Selina
while incarcerated
Bruce forms an unlikely alliance with a
very familiar man known only as John Doe
who reveals that lady Arkham is in fact
Gotham Gazette reporter Vicki Vale born
Vicki Arkham she was orphaned following
her parents assassination the one
ordered by Bruce's father and taken in
by the abusive fails the Arkham's did
not approve of what her dad and his
partners were doing upon escaping the
asylum that John's assistance his
investigation leads him to Vicki's home
where he discovers both her adoptive
parents murdered and the location of the
chemicals used to create the
mind-altering drug her parents before we
can deal with lady Arkham Bruce must
contend with the penguin who is
attempting to hack Wayne Tech's Network
and Harvey Dent who has turned Gotham
into a brutal police state naturally he
manages both his Batman after all just
cut me down Knight and is finally free
to deal with Vicki Vale who was
kidnapped and tortured his faithful
servant Alfred and is now attempting to
free the inmates of Arkham Asylum the to
battle in an unstable underground
chamber with the ensuing scuffle causing
the ancient structure to collapse
apparently killing Vale in the process
[Music]
in the aftermath players have the option
to address the public as Bruce
apologizing for the actions of his
father and offering to use his wealth to
rebuild Gotham this inspiring speech is
soon interrupted by a failed
assassination attempt and the season
ends with Bruce concentrating who is
behind the attack
so what can we expect from the enemy
within according to telltale both Batman
and Bruce Wayne will be forced into
precarious new roles the Dark Knight
will have to deal with new threat the
Riddler while navigating uneasy
alliances with old friends and enemies
as Bruce Wayne he will have to undertake
a perilous series of deceptions that
could see him going to some very dark
places and just like season 1 absolutely
anything can happen
it's a brand new story and telltale is
not afraid to change canon John Doe the
still embryonic Joker has been released
and believes Bruce is his friend through
the choices you make during season two a
Joker will be created and defined by
your words and actions no pressure there
then so that's everything you need to
know before playing Batman the enemy
within
brought to you by Telltale Games episode
1 of 5 is out now on ps4 Xbox one and PC
let us know what you'd like to see
happen in season 2 in the comments below
and be sure to stick with GameSpot
for more Batman videos